it had been a long day Expeditions like
this were normally tiring but with the
intense heat of the Egyptian sun bearing
down on them every minute felt like ours
and every hour a lifetime Seth and Kayla
were determined not to quit they had
traveled Halfway Around the World to get
to this site and they weren't about to
let the elements stop them from
uncovering the secrets they were
searching for the rumors had dated back
centuries stories of a hidden tomb lost
somewhere out in the desert and as a
likely pair of budding Adventurer and an
accomplished archaeologist neither one
of them could resist the chance to try
and hunt down the tomb if they could
uncover it they'd have one of the
greatest archaeological finds of the
century on their hands both Kayla and
Seth would forever be remembered as the
ones who discovered a supposedly
unfindable ancient tomb having found
their way to some ruins the remains of a
temple that had been all but raised to
the ground ravaged by the forces of time
Kayla and Seth had started searching for
the tomb's entrance the reason it had
stayed uncovered for so long was the
amount of sand that had covered it over
the centuries storms from the desert
constantly rearranging the grains and
piling on more but right now the skies
were clear and all they could do was
keep digging until at long last their
shovels struck Stone clearing a path to
the entrance Kayla flipped on a torch as
she led her archaeologist friend down a
flight of stairs carved into the stone
Seth followed her as they Traverse
further and further down the air getting
stale the deeper they went the whole
while there was a non-concern at the
back of both of their minds that the
rocky ceiling above could give way at
any moment trapping them both
underground but before each of them
could voice their worry out loud they
arrived at a large stone door left wide
open about 20 meters beneath the surface
is this really it Kayla asked in
disbelief it might be so replied the
excitement in his voice like that of a
kid on Christmas morning standing before
them beyond the threshold of the open
entrance was a chamber of stone its
ceiling was Secure about seven meters
high and the walls had been covered in
hieroglyphics immediately Seth shot over
to the nearest wall pulling a battered
Journal out of his bag to start to try
to translate what had been written while
he was doing that Kayla's attention fell
over the rest of the room for a tomb
there was a surprising lack of a
sarcophagus nor any other similar
resting place for a body with no signs
that anyone else had already been here
to remove one either all there really
was within was a few bowls randomly
placed around the chamber Kayla's
Torchlight fell over one of the bowls
and she knelt down to take a closer look
at its contents it was filled with bread
they were all holding different foods
dates figs dried fish and lentils of
course it wasn't uncommon for offerings
to be left with deceased during an
ancient Egyptian burial but strangely
none of these perishable foods seem to
have decayed in the centuries this tomb
had been lost for in fact it all looked
quite fresh like it was still good
enough to eat although the temptation to
actually eat any of it quickly
disappeared when Kayla reminded herself
that while it might not book it the food
down here had to have been hundreds
maybe thousands of years old despite how
perfectly preserved it appeared I think
I've got something Seth called
enthusiastically there's definitely a
story in these hieroglyphics you sure
were in the right place Kayla asked as
she crossed the room to where her
colleague was for a tomb it doesn't seem
like anyone was ever buried here I've
got a theory he replied this place might
be more of a metaphorical tomb right
that makes complete sense her sarcasm
was unmistakable look here he said
pointing to one of the drawings on the
wall as he spoke it depicted a figure
laying dead in a square space I think
that's meant to be this room someone
dies here and then Seth's finger moved
to another of the hieroglyphics one that
Kayla recognized it showed a being with
the body of a man and the head of a
jackal taking the dead figure down into
the Afterlife this was a new
one of the ancient Egyptian gods
associated with the afterlife according
to Legends and other texts gathered from
the pyramids in Giza Anubis oversaw the
process the Egyptians would perform to
embalm their dead preserving them for
their trip to the next World Anubis
takes whoever they are to the Judgment
Hall of the afterlife to be brought
before Seth explained only to be cut off
Osiris got a fertility the afterlife and
the dead Kayla interrupted she had
already spotted the next being depicted
in the glyphs a tall figure with a
distinctive headpiece holding a symbolic
Crook and flail oversaw Resurrection
Life probably many other things yeah he
was a god with a few different hats Seth
attempted to joke well just the same one
had he's always shown wearing also
technically not a hat the Atif was a
type of crown and so hold on Kayla
interjected again didn't Osiris only
bring the Pharaohs in for judgment who
was this person that died I mean the
Egyptians never went to this amount of
trouble for their Average Joes and the
gods wouldn't pay them any mind unless
there were important somehow I'm not
sure Seth answered earnestly at any rate
this could all just be a myth that's why
I think this tomb is metaphorical it
wasn't built to house a dead person but
to keep people believing she finished
his sentence for him he then pointed out
the next part of the glyphs the dead
figure arriving in the afterlife carried
by Anubis for judgment and then handing
an object to Osiris Seth explained there
was a certain myth surrounding Osiris
and his resurrection a story that told
of all of his dead body parts being
found except one without it the God
could not be fully resurrected my theory
is that is Osiris's missing appendage as
it were Seth's face was red as he tried
to keep his composure after our
mysterious friend handed it over the
hieroglyphs showed the nameless dead
figure being taken from anubis's Hand by
Osiris who then placed them back in the
room they had started in the same
chamber Seth and Kayla were standing in
it seemed they had been resurrected
after death giving Osiris something that
the God had wanted had earned this
figure a free pass back to the land of
the living the glyphs also showed bowls
of food around the tomb like the ones
Kayla had found dotted around the room
there was a type of Aura drawn around
the unknown figure now almost like a
personal Shield according to the
drawings and symbols on the walls and
Seth's hastily translation of their
meaning this was some form of protection
granted by Osiris himself the arrow was
meant to prevent the figure from harm
meaning they couldn't die again however
the next portion of the story showed
Anubis damaging The Shield possibly out
of jealousy or spite or perhaps defying
Osiris tampering with the natural Order
of Things by protecting the figure from
Death as well as causing damage to the
aura of immortality that Osiris had
bestowed upon them Anubis trained the
figure of all of their blood which then
caused them to go and do the same to
others Seth continued interpreting allow
it would find people drink their blood
to sustain it like don't say it Kayla's
side I mean it's a lot like a VIP Egypt
gave us mummies they can't have another
native monster from horror B movies she
interrupted well maybe the legend found
its way here somehow or at least a more
ancient Egyptian version of it her
counterpart tried to reason it looks
like here the figure was Far healthier
after consuming blood see how the aura
around them is repaired now but Seth
look at what they're standing on Kayla
whispered one of the final images in the
glyphs did display exactly what Seth had
described but beneath the feet of the
figure who now seemed replenished was a
mass of bodies a pile of human corpses
with one person standing at the very top
who would want to live forever anyway
Kayla muttered almost inaudibly hey come
and have a look at these leaning over
she picked up one of the food bowls from
the floor brimming with offerings of
dates she handed it to Seth who marveled
at how well preserved the food was
that's incredible he remarked this ball
looks like it's at least several
thousand years old and guess maybe 2500
BCE but the dates he put one out of the
bowl and sniffed it put it back and then
did the same with another making sure it
wasn't a fluke the conditions couldn't
possibly have kept them fresh so how is
it there are bowls of food all over this
room that still look edible she asked I
honestly have no he began to say but the
sound of heavy grinding stone
interrupted Seth's sentence both he and
Kayla looked in horror as they witnessed
the entrance of the Tomb being sealed
the heavy stone door dropping moments
away from sealing them in Seth we need
to run Kayla urged grabbing her bag if
we move now we can get out of here
before we get shut in but Seth protested
looking around the tomb the glyph walls
that had only just been discovered
nobody would know that he and Kayla had
found them if they ran now he looked
around the room pondering for a moment
his eyes darting from a bowl of bread to
the bowl of dates in his hands we should
at least take photos no time our lives
aren't worth proving what we found
better to make it out than be buried
alive Kayla shouted darting towards the
entrance ducking under the slowly
lowering stone door Seth come on she
called from the other side despite her
calls for him to move her fellow
Explorer didn't follow he just stood
there watching the door get lower and
the only way back to the surface get
narrower by the time it had completely
closed Kayla's voice sounded so much
further away that Seth could barely make
out what she was saying I'll get help
find some way to get you out Kayla
screamed at the wall now separating her
from the tomb if you can hear me Seth
ration the water in your bag take small
sips every few hours Seth already knew
that the human body could survive around
three weeks on just water and no food
and he trusted Kayla would have figured
out how to get him out by then he gave
another glance to the food bowls
scattered throughout the tomb the idea
of eating any of it knowing how old it
all potentially was did turn his stomach
a little but if it came down to having
to eat just a bite in order to survive a
little longer Seth was sure it looked
fresh enough to still be edible it
couldn't hurt to take a bite right over
the next few days Seth's Focus was spent
entirely on photographing and
transcribing more of the hieroglyphics
occasionally stopping to take swigs of
water from his canteen if anything it
was more to combat how warm and stuffy
it was being locked inside the stone
chamber 20 meters underground meanwhile
unseen to Seth outside Kayla was working
tirelessly to try and figure out a way
to get the door open she had been
searching for days for any sign or some
kind of switch or lever that would
unseal the chamber entrance there had to
be some mechanism that had caused the
stone door to shut itself in the first
place but there was nothing around that
looked like it fit that description as
much as she urged Seth to abandon his
archaeological Finders Keepers Pride
Kayla was hesitant to make the long
journey back across the desert to Cairo
to get help anyone she brought to the
dig site might claimed the discovery as
their own and more to the point the more
time she spent traveling across the
desert for help the more more time Seth
would spend trapped succumbing to
gradual dehydration and starvation
little was Kayla aware it was already
too late Seth hadn't been observing her
warning about managing the amounts of
water he was drinking and pretty soon
his canteen was empty he cursed himself
annoyed for being so involved in his
discovery that he'd now potentially put
his own life at risk but then he
remembered the food bowls kneeling down
he picked up the nearest one the same
bowl with all the dates in it shaking
his head at the thought he put them back
down again the longer he waited the more
Seth began to worry that maybe Kayla had
abandoned him and if she had and he was
faced with the inevitability that he
would die down here lost and forgotten
in an ancient tomb underground he
couldn't help but find something ironic
about the whole thing he was going to
die in a tomb whose walls told the tale
of a dead person being brought back to
life maybe in a few hundred years more
archaeologists would find this buried
room and think he was the the one the
tomb had been constructed for even
trying to put an ironic spin on things
wasn't enough to give Seth much peace
when staring down the possibility he
might not see the Sun and walk above
ground again and getting closer to death
is what made him want to avoid it
tempting him towards the bowls of food
every time he tried to remind himself
not to touch any of it the pain in his
stomach swelled even greater reminding
him of his own hunger with no clear view
of the sky Seth had little clue just how
many days he'd been trapped in the Tomb
although he was sure it was approaching
the day 4 threshold he couldn't survive
much longer beyond that point without
eating as the days dragged on he
abandoned his research and note-taking
it was impossible to focus on
translating hieroglyphics when he was in
so much pain aching from the Heat and
having no food or water exhaustion
causing him to pass out his body trying
to conserve its already limited reserves
of energy eventually Seth started trying
to rationalize eating at least a date or
two the food hadn't decomposed or rotted
at all even introducing air from outside
when the tomb was first open hadn't
changed the state of any of it at all
not the dates nor the bread or the fish
it still looked fresh and edible and
after God knows how long without eating
it was beginning to look all the more
appealing to the starving archaeologist
who cares if it had been there for a
thousand years or longer if Seth didn't
eat he knew he wouldn't last much longer
the moment he chewed on the first date
feeling it passed down his esophagus
passing from his mouth to his stomach
Seth immediately regretted giving in to
his need to eat his mouth instantly went
dry far worse than it had been after
this long without water it was like the
tiny piece of fruit had pulled all the
saliva from his mouth Seth tried to
scream and panic only to release a horse
dry-throated grasp as he felt his tongue
shriveling up with his mouth and throat
until it felt like the skin of a drum
but it didn't stop there it only got
worse Seth stared in horror at his own
arms the blue veins that ran underneath
his skin rapidly draining away his
forearms and biceps shrunk muscle and
sinew shriveling like his body had been
left in a water evaporator all the while
the pain of having his entire physical
form being reshaped was pure Agony the
dehydration of his mouth meant Seth
still couldn't scream only dropped to
the ground as he felt the same thing
happening to his legs every drop of
moisture in his body every fluid from
water to blood saliva and even urine was
drying out leaving Seth as little more
than a Dusty desiccated husk before his
own eyes he could only watch as his skin
lost its pigment drawing into a thin
leathery texture drained of its original
color as his blood stopped flowing
outside Kayla had been coming back to
the tomb sealed door every day and would
stay until the late hours of the evening
she tried digging down from the surface
to reach the chamber where Seth had been
trapped but it was too far underground
there was no sign of any way to move or
reopen the stone door that is until she
heard the heavy grinding of it opening
on its own Kayla raced down the steps
towards the tomb it had been five whole
days since she and Seth got separated
and he'd need food and medical attention
sprinting into the dark tunnel she
arrived just in time to see the entrance
reopening expecting to see Seth standing
on the other side as the stone door
lifted which he saw instead was a
nightmare it looked like a corpse an
ancient and decomposing dead body Kayla
had seen plenty entombed in sarcophagi
on her many travels exploring ancient
ruins around the world but she had never
seen one standing up it was still
breathing a wheezing raspy sound
escaping its mouth its skin looked
almost brittle as if it was stretched
too thin almost see-through enough to
show off the bones underneath the
upright Corpse's face was all wrong too
sunken cheeks and eye sockets deeper
than they should have been it looked so
different that it wasn't until kale has
shown her flashlight on its drained face
that she recognized who it was Seth he
lunged at her immediately racing towards
her snarling with his dry desiccated
mouth Kayla turned and ran as he came
after her bony fingers swiping at her
clothes her flashlight gripped in her
hand was all but useless as she sprinted
back the way she'd come swinging back
and forth in her arm barely Illuminating
much of the cavern that led to the tomb
the whole while she was running from it
she could hear the wheezing behind of
Seth behind her terrified of whatever he
had become and why he was chasing her
then she saw it the stairs her one shot
at getting out and getting away if she
could make it to the surface she could
put some more distance between herself
and the drained dehydrated corpse all
she had to do was make it up the last
step she just made it when she felt the
shriveling hand grip her ankle tripping
her over falling face first in the sand
Kayla scrabbled at the loose grains
trying to pull herself away as her body
was dragged back down onto the stone
stairs she fell felt a searing pain and
screamed into the empty desert as The
Corpse's fingers dug into her neck its
leathery dry skin against hers
eventually the screaming stopped
replaced with a dry horse gasping and
then silence as Seth drained her body of
her blood along with the rest pulling
Kayla's Body by her ankle Seth dragged
whatever was left of her back down
towards the tomb
scp-3359 to feed on what was left now go
and check out scp-1176 why everyone
wants to eat this corpse for even more
mysterious mummified Madness or if
ancient temples are more your thing then
why not take a visit to
scp-001 God's blind spot and uncover
some Sinister secrets with some
anomalous technology